I want to highlight a story from a part
of the world where women actually are
genuinely treated like garbage and the
left almost never seems to do anything
to try to stand up for them uh beauty
salon banned in Afghanistan is a blow to
women's Financial Freedom so this is
basically a story about how in
Afghanistan now that the Taliban are in
charge they have officially banned
beauty salons for women they're shutting
down businesses that these women have
spent their their lives building we have
a story of a 34 year old mother
of two who's not going to have her
business anymore it really is a a sad
story I think as you know an evil Pro
man Pro patriarchy person who thinks
that anything that's bad for women is
bad for men and anything that's bad for
men is bad for women I gotta say you
know I hold very strongly to Traditional
Values I don't think there's anything
against traditional uh values or
traditional sensibilities of wanting
women to be able to go to beauty salons
something like this is just so horrible
and senseless but of course the only
time the left really wants to talk about
the condition of women living under
Theocratic Islamic regimes is when they
want to compare themselves to someone
because politics in America didn't go
their way you can't even go to school
yeah where's the squad where's the Elon
Omar yep where's LLC
about this today this is Ariana Presley
where are they they're nowhere and it's
because there's no consistency in their
logic right I mean so we're going to
point out in this article that without
these beauty salons which are women only
anyways because of the culture and uh
the Theocratic role in Afghanistan there
are no places where women can publicly
assemble without a male chaperone like
they can be in their homes and that's it
and women in America believe they are
oppressed I mean I just I just find it
deeply ironic and in some ways
insensitive right the next time they're
saying you know we're with her I want to
ask you who is her this is relative
terrible grammar this is relativism
because in a lot of ways what it is is
there you're told here in America
because we focus so much on ideological
bounds that are on Race sexuality and
gender is that stay in your lane you
can't comment on what's going on there
because you inherently can't understand
their culture and a lot of the people
that believe that haven't traveled the
world they haven't been outside the US
they have no frame of reference outside
of that so you're just instead of having
the uncomfortable conversation that you
might want to criticize something about
somebody who might not look like you or
might not be from the same place as you
the idea is to just push the can down
the road and ignore it pretend like it's
not happening and Hannah Claire this
whole business about women in America
being oppressed is laughable every every
year that hear that woman that Obama was
in office
he would come out and talk about how
women make X number of sense on the
dollar compared to men so if that were
true you would fire all your men hire
women and pocket the difference uh there
are more women now in college than men
the numbers of women entering medical
school and law school equal the number
of of men graduation stats too right
graduation stats women live longer I
mean it 90 of the people behind bars are
men I mean where how where are they
oppressed this is the only uh instance
in history that I'm familiar with of an
oppressed class being more likely to win
custody battles being more likely to
receive more lenient sentences crimes
more likely to vote more likely to
receive a higher education more likely
to be considered for uh Elite programs
such as being admitted into a stem field
based on their application it's really
man a difficult kind of impression
that's a pressure peel me off some of
that yeah exactly exactly
that's what the women in Afghanistan
would say yeah we want the Western
American oppression thank you even so
right what we have to consider is
because of the the sexual Revolution and
modern feminism and basically the way
I've described feminism in the past is
it's it's essentially especially in the
west
um a PR campaign for the sexual
Revolution to try to get women to
co-sign their own debasement into basing
what we've done is we've reduced women
to objects in a different way where now
all you exist to do is be sexually
appealing to men and once you've done
that and a human person is just a thing
and their value is merely a product of
what they can give you and a woman is
just a sexual object well once a man
through surgical intervention can
emulate the secondary sex
characteristics of Womanhood that you
find appealing now he can be a woman too
I mean we lose everything and Sheamus I
think it's also driven by power and by
politics if the left convinces women
that they are oppressed the same thing
as convincing blacks that they're that
they're still subject second-class
citizens yeah it's the same kind of
thing we are the party wearing the white
hat uh and social justice for women and
for minorities and these guys over here
these National Republicans they were the
black hat
the meme it says like uh it says
Republicans are racist Republicans if
they got to pick the Supreme Court it's
just all Clarence Thomas
it's just a bunch of clearance houses
it's it's also like for for this topic I
think it's a lot to do with when you
take the when you divide the men and
women that way you make them when you
make it the woman an object you are now
inherently stopping the family from
forming right so that you start it's
just Marxism it just it just ends up
dividing the family further it makes us
enemies right like I don't want to live
in a world where I don't believe I can
live a happy life alongside men
hopefully with a man when I'm married
you know what I mean like I want to
believe that we are meant to be uh
complementary and to build each other up
through our unique strengths I don't
think that that is the culture that uh
aggressive left tells us and I think
that's inherently destructive right so
not only are we destroying the family by
separating kids from the parents but we
are separating men from women saying you
guys are actually enemies right
especially if you're a man you are the
problem and you should eat yourself
that's that's Benny uh Thompson who is a
chair of the so-called January 6
Insurrection committee she's publicly
referred to Clarence Thomas as an Uncle
Tom it's unbelievable it's unbelievable
you know it's so disgusting this
rhetoric that you hear when when people
try to pile on somebody because they
have the wrong opinion they belong to
some kind of minority group as happens
to you it happens that basically anyone
else who speaks out against the left
from the vantage point of someone in a
group that they quote unquote represent
they end up being tarred and feathered
and what's so particularly heinous about
it is
you know if if somebody tells you as a
member of the out group that they don't
like you so like if a white person says
something bad to a black person or a
black person says something bad to a
white person that's bad but at the very
least there hasn't been this narrative
created that like your own in-group is
rejecting you your own family your own
friends people in your community are
rejecting you to tell someone like you
are actually you actually don't fit in
with the category that you're a part of
it's a far worse way of learning Spanish
from the village we were talking about
Thomas Soul earlier oh he's incredible
there's a magazine called Ebony magazine
it comes out once a month it's not
nearly the got the cloud it used to have
but virtually every black family had it
on the coffee table we did for decades
and every year they'd have a feature
called the 100 most influential black
Americans and every year absent from
that list Thomas Soul Walter Williams
and even Clarence Thomas how is that
possible Thomas Seoul has written about
40 books uh David Mamet the playwright
referred to Thomas Soul as America's
greatest contemporary philosopher Walter
Williams is the first to my knowledge
only a chair of an economics Department
of a non-historically black College
written a number of books both Thomas so
and he have had hundreds of outlets in
their syndicated column and most black
people don't know who the hell they are
because they've been banished from the
village can I ask how did your
Republican father respond to this did he
point this out to you was this a
conversation you had at home no and this
this is just something that I that I
observe my Republican father said this
about the Democrats Democrats want to
give you something for nothing when
you're trying to get something for
nothing you almost always end up getting
nothing for something
speaking of which very good speaking of
which in order for me to qualify for
that next debate yes next month in
August 23rd is the debate I need to have
donations from 40 000 individuals you
can donate as little as one dollar just
go to my website Larry
elderforpresident.com or larryelder.com
one dollar this vast audience one dollar
even if you want somebody else talk
about the kinds of things we're talking
about the epidemic or fatherlessness the
lie that America systemically raises the
need for an amendment to fix spending to
a certain percentage of the GDP school
choice I even have a proposed
legislation to get rid of these soft on
crime George Soros back the age that's
great and that's on my website Larry
yoda.com so even if you want somebody
else to put those issues front and
center have me up there hold my beer so
just one dollar and it's just one dollar
they only have to donate one dollar
that's gonna help you get on stage 40
000 individual donations what kind of
debate do you want guys we want an
interesting debate yeah yeah up there or
what the black face of white supremacy
In the Flesh I had to I send it good
season form I sent that article to
somebody when because there's a lot of
people I still have a lot of friends
that are very liberal I still consider
myself fairly liberal on a lot of issues
but I have a lot of friends who just
don't know that a lot of this stuff is
going and it took an article about the
black face of white supremacy to
actually wake somebody up to the
absolute Ridiculousness that was a
headline it was a headline headline was
Larry Elder is the black face the white
supremacy sub headline you've been
warned yes did you find it and by the
way the woman that wrote her initials
are Erica D Smith oops and I invited her
on my radio show when the race was over
because I had two months left in my
contract and she wouldn't come on
well she can't platform white
supremacist right do you have this Frame
down your wall no but I will yeah you
should I do so I worked very hard for
that title yeah I actually see what the
hell okay so so when we're talking about
like the power like I talk a lot about
the power of the media and the most
powerful thing they can do is not talk
about something oh yeah uh that's what
I'm talking when you're we're talking
Thomas Soul we're talking about the fact
that you're saying that almost all these
black Americans don't know that Thomas
still exists that's because he's not
revered he's not actually put in to the
public Spotlight by anyone that they
would actually watch media from and all
they would have to do is highlight him
highlight his work but they don't
because he doesn't co-sign The Narrative
this is a story I don't believe I've
ever mentioned publicly you remind me of
it
um I had a book New York Times
bestseller book called The 10 things you
can't say in America first chapter was
blacks are more racist than white second
chapter is white condescension is as bad
as black racism and another chapter
about the war on drugs and about the war
on guns at first when it was Chris Rock
uh was it Chris Rock bit well because he
said but it's because they hate black
people too
I have a friend who Jesse Jackson does
not know is my friend and he my friend
used to work for operation rainbow push
in Chicago and he said Jesse Jackson's
office had a bunch of books bookcase
behind his desk but the books on his
table are the ones he was really reading
and there was a copy of my book on the
on his table and I
hit Jesse Jackson often in my book he
told me there was a conference call with
a bunch of so-called black leaders and
they said what are we going to do about
this mofo named Larry Elder and he said
they all agreed the star the smartest
strategy was to Simply ignore me exactly
and that's what they've done and I told
you all these years I've tried to get
these guys to come on they won't come on
they simply have ignored me they won't
even mention my name yep and they made a
group decision
she's so creepy um firstly the just to
touch on the fact that Thomas Saul
wasn't mentioned it's it's not just like
Thomas Sowell is some intellectual who
happened to be black like he is one of
the best political thinkers today he's
brilliant anyone who's read his work and
he speaks so clearly too he's not all
over the place he doesn't have trouble
finding his thoughts he just puts
everything out there in a perfectly like
concise and reasonable way and in
everything he's written that I've read
has been fantastic but of course he's
ignored because he's coming to
conclusions which are very clearly true
on the number things I don't agree with
him on everything but even when I
disagree with him he makes a remarkable
case it's thoughtful thanks for watching
this clip from the timcast IRL podcast
hang out with us live Monday through
Friday at 8 pm and become a member over
at timcast.com for uncensored members
only shows exclusive thanks for hanging
out and we'll see you all next time